hi everyone I'm Casey Olin hoot I'm
program manager on the dotnet and visual
studio team at Microsoft hopefully some
of you all came out last night at the
dotnet User Group maybe some of you and
saw me walk through like what was new
individuals to 2017 and part of that I
showed what Roslyn analyzers were so in
today's session we're gonna go through
how you can build a rosin analyzer and
then like what the heck that even is etc
alright so here's a brief agenda for
those of you who like to know what we're
gonna do up front so we'll talk about
what analyzers are what this mysterious
Roslyn thing is we'll go through the
different api's that exist what tools
you need to build an analyzer and then
we'll build an analyzer and a fixer and
then you can join our awesome
third-party ecosystem if you want all
right but why should anyone care like
why are you here well then the top
feedbacks we get in visual studio just
in general for productivity is people
say I wish I had a refactoring that did
XYZ or can't you make you know like
remove all my log line calls for me or
can you convert these multi-line strings
that I have to a single line and so
people have all these or like you know
you might have a super weird naming
convention on your team that we don't
support and you want to throw an error
if people like you violate it and don't
use that naming convention and so these
are top requests that we get but as the
compiler team it doesn't make sense for
us to make these compiler errors and
force them on the entire world and so
that's why rosin analyzers exist so that
you can write your own to enforce
whatever you want on yourself on your
team for your library etc and so here is
just an example of what a rose and
analyzer looks like it's that squiggle
that you see letting you know that
there's a violation so that's part of
the diagnostic and they can use the
light bulb to provide a fixer that will
then fix whatever your error was and so
that's the main point is that if there
is something that you want to use to
make your life easier so there's some
repetitive task you're doing over and
over again with refactoring or code
generation etc this is what
can use an analyzer for and then if you
are a library author this is probably my
favorite example so the xunit team you
may have noticed like one day like your
ex unit nougat package upgraded and you
have the copa jillion errors you're like
what just happened and that was because
he added a rosin analyzer nougat package
to their nougat so that you get this
sort of enforcement to help you learn
how to properly properly use X unit so
here people were using the attributes
incorrectly for different types and so
here they offer the fixes to help you
make it actually compile it and work
based on how they did their library and
so if you're a library author you can
use these to help enforce the right way
of using your API so that's another
reason why you might want to look into
writing these so I'm not gonna truly
demo something right now but I'm going
to show you how approachable these are
hopefully so this is what one looks like
on github alright so this is just an
analyzer that squiggles if a logline
exists so it was that initial screenshot
you can see all my code fits on just
this little screen right here all this
up here is boilerplate and the only real
code I wrote was right down here and so
that's like seven lines of code
essentially so that's how approachable
these things are to writing it's not
like once you get your wrap your head
around the concepts putting it together
is not very many lines of code at all
and the fixer is like ten lines of code
so that's just a brief look at where
we're headed at the end of this talk to
let you know like you know it's gonna be
okay we're get through this compilers
can be cool alright so back to the
PowerPoint all right so what is an
analyzer an analyzer has two parts the
first is mandatory and not optional so
that's the diagnostic diagnostic is just
the squiggle that we put that put in the
editor so
you know if you have that blog line call
you say oh where do I want to draw the
squiggle so there's a known violation
and then if you have that it's going to
break the build if you have an error so
Diagnostics run anywhere that your code
runs so run your CI whatever and then
the optional part that an analyzer can
have is a fixer a fixer is tied to UI so
it must be in Visual Studio or soon
hopefully you can write one analyzer
that will work with vs code and brittle
studio for Mac when you do that it's
tied to that UI so again it won't run
you can't like have these fixers running
your CI but you can use them inside
Visual Studio to then fix however you
want so that's the two main parts of an
analyzer and we're going to build both
of them so what is this thing Rozlyn
that I keep talking about Roslyn is the
codename for our project the true name
is the dotnet compiler platform but like
that doesn't mean anything anyway so my
as was call it Roslyn and so Roslyn is
where we completely reaaargh attacted
the c-sharp and visual basic compiler
from native code into managed code I
think it took six years seven years to
do that so a long time and you might be
like why the heck would you do that
great question
there's two main reasons we did it the
first was so that we could write new
features faster by features I mean new
language features so if you went to you
know Mads and John session yesterday or
their session today you probably saw
that like where are you talking about
c-sharp 8 and it's been I don't know
anymore it's been full okay so if for
years since I joined the team and that
was when c-sharp 6 came out and now
there's been seven seven point one seven
point two seven point three and now
we're like talking about eight already
and have prototypes which just shows how
fast language development can happen now
we can do these point releases we can
get you prototypes things that we could
never have done on the old compiler that
we had also we can write new IDE
features faster so any were factoring
that you see in Visual Studio you may
have noticed like every update or point
release of Visual Studio we also have
more fixes and more refactorings
that's because it becomes almost trivial
for us to write them not really but like
compared to how it used to be and then
the second reason that we did it so why
do we are attacked all of this so that
we could create an open-source API
surface over the entire compiler so that
anyone could write a code focused tool
or technology and so this is very
analyzers come from so now rather than
the compiler being this sort of black
box where you don't know what's
happening in there and also in spits out
il and it's all good
you can now with it being opened up
access all of these different api's that
we've made available to build what you
need and so here I've just abstracted
them out into the four main api's
there's a lot more but you know here is
the gist and then here's what you can
sort of build with them so the syntax
tree API it's high fidelity
representation of your source code
that's how you write formatting tools
because whitespace matters and
formatting the symbol API is where you
want more semantic key related things
like if you want to navigate two types
or members the binding API let's do
things like extract method and then the
emit API which if you truly want to do
some crazy stuff you can use that
that's what edit continued for example
is built on today so that's like an
overview of what api's we have now let's
dig into the first two because those are
the two that we'll be using today so the
syntax tree API this is my rough sketch
of a syntax tree to make it as less
scary as possible so a syntax tree has
notes nodes represent syntactic
constructs like you know declarations
expressions etc and then you have tokens
which are these green things and tokens
are like you know key words literals
identifiers what-have-you and then we
have trivia which is what makes our
syntax tree perhaps different than other
ones you've seen is that all this white
space and like preprocessor directives
and comments are all captured in our
syntax tree as well so that's important
if you're writing on these tools that
does a refactoring or
or moves code around you want to keep
comments or duplicate comments you need
that information and so all of that is
in our syntax tree so it's a high
fidelity representation of your source
code the to then properties of the
syntax tree are that again if the
complete representation of your code and
that they're immutable and they're
mutable that's important because then
you know if multiple users are working
on that syntax tree
you're not having like mixed up state so
it's like I work on my syntax tree I do
something see if it can be applied if it
can't throw it out do it again
kind of thing rather than us all
mutating this same tree and then getting
in some crazy state with your code the
other advantage of it being immutable is
for those of you who are in brittle
studio 2015 or 2017 you probably have
seen this little dip few when you access
the light bulb where we do a live diff
and that's because we have two trees
because they're immutable and we can
diff them and show you what the code
change is gonna do and so just another
like from the tooling perspective what
we're able to do with these syntax trees
being immutable so pretty cool the other
API we're in time out is the semantic
model the semantic model lets you access
semantic information so like you know is
this a field or is this a property what
is the name of this method what is the
type of this parameter so if you want
the answers to those questions you need
to ask the semantic model and that's
where that comes in the semantic model
also has knowledge of the compilation so
if we need something from metadata etc
you can get that from your semantic
model all right
so how these two api's interact with
each other so your syntax tree your
semantic model how do they work together
well from a node in your syntax tree you
then ask questions to your semantic
model like what type am i and the
semantic model will then return that to
you and so that's how you can like go
through you're like oh I'm at this node
I need more information I'm gonna get my
semantic model ask it some questions get
the answer and continue on my merry way
which is all fine and dandy
except what if you don't
need that sort of like nitty-gritty
information from your syntax tree like
you're writing something that only has
to do with semantics you don't care
about whitespace you don't care about
comments you're never going to touch
them what do you do well we have this
new tree called I operation which is
what we're gonna use later today and I
operation is a higher level of
abstraction over this so for example you
know if you have multiple shapes of the
same thing in the language it can
abstract over both those shapes and it's
so high level that it even abstract over
languages so you can write one analyzer
using the eye operation API that works
for Visual Basic and c-sharp so that's
important to you and your team that's
what you can do here but it also works
across shapes within the same language
which we'll see an example of that in a
second how I operation works in this
entire model that we have set up is you
get your operation from your semantic
model and then from your eye operation
tree then if you need more nitty-gritty
information you can go back and ask
questions to your syntax tree to get
information like what is my span or my
location in this document and then here
are the reasons why you would use the
different API so if you care about
formatting or syntax patterns you would
use your syntax tree API if you only
care about semantic patterns or if you
need that cross language support then
operation might be the thing for you
all right so that was like a lot so
let's take a sec recap slide so again
there's a syntax tree that's the high
fidelity representation of your source
code includes whitespace all sorts of
other trivia you have the semantic model
where you learn semantic information
then you have eye operation which is
like the newest evolution of the Rosslyn
api's that gives that's abstract over
syntactic shapes and it's probably more
similar to what you all may have liked
in school learned as a syntax tree and
then the last API that we're going to
use today when we write our fixer is the
syntax generator which allows you to
language agnostic Li create syntax so
we'll get into that but the gist of a
fixer is that you're gonna go and create
a new sub tree where you're going to
have the syntax of the fix and then
you're gonna swap it into that original
syntax tree out with the note that you
want to change and then return that new
syntax tree that's essentially how a fix
is gonna work all right
so that was like a lot and that's like
the theory yada yada is let's like build
something so that's sound good all right
so you have tools we made this easy we
have like templates for you there's like
you know our documentation which is just
the source code and then install
instructions now so this is how you get
started the tools that you're really
gonna want are the syntax visualizer
which comes with the SDK and then these
analyzers are in fixer templates that we
provide for you and then the link to our
documentation is just source dot
Rosalind IO which is lets you like
symbolically navigate our source code
from the web when you're in Visual
Studio or installing it if you want to
get the SDK right away you just like go
to the work load that's the Visual
Studio extension development one and
then make sure that highlighted spot is
checked and that's how you can get the
templates to write these cool all right
so what is art what are we gonna build
today we're going to build an analyzer
that finds every spot where you've nude
up a zero length array and we're gonna
suggest that you use array dot empty
instead so just like reduce number of
allocations that you make that's all
we're gonna do so we're gonna be looking
for any place that you knew up empty or
a zero length array and then suggest
that you do this instead now if we did
this with the syntactic tree API we
would have to look and realize that
there's two different ways to new up a
zero length array right there's the way
on the left and there's the way on the
right and when you're you know dealing
with syntax like these are looking
lately different so their syntax trees
are totally different this is what the
first one looks like so you could see if
you want to see if it was a zero length
array you would go back you like follow
it down and then find that zero and say
oh it's of length zero but if you go the
other one it's a bit more monstrous
looking and then you come down and
there's like this omitted token thing
that you would have to look for inside
to be able to even tell that that was a
blank zero and so traditionally before I
operation you would have to go through
and parse these two different types of
syntax and account for both of those in
your analyzer to see if you found a zero
length array but this is where I
operation comes in and the eye operation
tree abstracts over these two different
shapes and there's just a concept of an
array creation and from that you can get
dimensions and things like that so I can
show you going to our handy dandy
documentation mmm the source code is
your source start rather than i/o you
can just like search in here so I'm just
searching for the eye operation and here
if i zoom in you can see here's the what
eye operation looks like has parents it
has kinds has syntax types etc and yeah
and so we'll just be coming back to this
frequently to figure out why things are
going on but this is the basis for how
we're gonna move forward for the rest of
the talk all right so now we're in
visual studio this is what you're gonna
want to do so when you do file new after
you've installed that SDK you're gonna
see this template so you can write an
analyzer with a code fix there's just a
template for it there's also a factoring
but we'll get into that later and so
yeah here's template that you want I
already have it open I deleted a lot of
the boilerplate so the initial one comes
with an example where it will find I
think all your class names and offer to
make them all uppercase so it's just
like a silly little example to show you
a basic analyzer and so we're gonna just
go through and
do this other one instead so I deleted
all the comments that are in here and
this is essentially what you have if all
fits I think the screen all right so
half of this is boilerplate or maybe
more all of us all this beautiful so
what is it doing this first chunk is
just giving you like what strings do you
want to appear to the user so like
what's the title what is the message
format the description etc and they're
all managing this resources file so I
could like come in here I don't know say
just so that you know that it's real as
well okay so just like at whatever you
want in here what messages you want to
appear when they hover when they do
control dot and get the light bulb etc
so I have that or like what shows in the
error list as well so that's all I was
in here the other thing you'll notice oh
I guess live unit testing died well okay
you can set a category for this as well
and then all these are bundled up into
something called a diagnostic descriptor
as this is something that describes your
diagnostic and so in here you can see
that comes with the ID then it takes
that title message category you can
choose what I'm sorry zoom zoom zoom you
can see nope all right I don't even know
why I'm using a mouse anyways okay here
we go
you can put the default severity of your
analyzer in here so if you want to be a
suggestion if you want to be off by
default whatever you can change it in
here you can come in here and see you
can make it like a warning error info or
hidden which means not showing it all
sorts Ben keep it as a warning because I
wrote unit test so we're just saying
Cupit that way so change anything and
that's just all bundled up into this
diagnostic descriptor and then this is
the main meat this is like the meat of
it we're just going to this initialize
function and then we're going to
register a callback
so when our code analysis goes through
this document we're gonna say hey when
you see a like array that's been created
I want you to see if it's of length 0
and if it is I want to report a
diagnostic and put in a squiggle that's
what we're doing here
so we're some common here and if I come
into my context so the only thing we
have available here is context when I do
this let's do some zoomin if I type
register you can see that you can
register all sorts of different actions
or like on different actions so like
typically people do like syntax so when
you see a syntax node you're looking for
this or at the start of a compilation or
when you see a code block etc because
we're using eye operation we're gonna
say when you see an operation so that's
what we're gonna start with and then
it's asking for our callback so we're
gonna call our callback like analyze
operation why not
and then it's looking for a kind so what
is our operation kind so when we see
what are we going to trigger this so if
we go back to our handy-dandy
documentation we can see that there's
the operation kind here we're gonna
click on this and see what kinds there
are and we're just gonna hope that
there's something called array something
and sure enough I missed it I was on it
in the beginning oh here we go you can
see that there's something called array
creation and it has this information so
it's tied to this and so if we click on
the IRA creation operation we can see
looking at it it has this beautiful
thing dimension sizes we're looking at
the dimension of our array so we don't
have to check those two different
syntaxes there's just one array creation
thing it has dimension sizes it doesn't
matter which type of new double zero
length array syntax you use so that's
what we're gonna use so we're coming
here have our operation kind we're
looking for that array creation I'm
gonna use control dot to generate this
method that's where that squiggle
because it hasn't been written yet if I
use control dot it'll generate it for me
I said that one whose expression body
members so I'm gonna come here and
switch it to a block body so you all can
read it and then I'm gonna rename this
to context so that matches my operation
analysis context better alright so now
that we're in here this is our callback
so we're what the heck are we gonna do
in this the gist of what we're gonna do
is why I said earlier we're just gonna
say hey we have this array creation
expression is it zero length and are the
so are the dimension sizes zero and if
they are report a diagnostic so we're
gonna come in here we're gonna get our
array creation expression so from our
context we can get the operation we're
gonna cast it though as that I array
creation operation so now we have our
array creation then we're just gonna say
hey if this thing has a dimension so if
has that if it has a dimension then
we're gonna come in here rate creation
dimension sizes
grab it because we know it's a length
one and so if you're wondering what
these stars are by the way I had like
we're doing this for a and to how a I
assistive technology can make developers
more productive and so this is like we
machine learned on some github repos I
figured out based on people's context
what members of different types and
stuff are they using and then we're
putting them at the top and so I guess
the version the model that we updated
yesterday has Rozlyn in it and so it's
trained on the Rozlyn code base and so
it's suggesting things that my team has
use here so that's why you see only
start things which they are going to
come in handy so constant value and then
has value is what I wanted you can see
like suggested it here if you can see
that so pretty handy I have to scroll
less now so it's helping me learn this
new API I'm unfamiliar with
once
in here I can grab my dimensions so come
here dimension sizes yep yep see it like
wrote that line for me beautiful so it
turns out though if I use one of our new
refactorings where you can toggle
between explicit type and the implicit
type dimension is an object so in order
to see if it's zero I have to do this
like you know thing that we hate if it's
an int and Casta as an int and then
check if it's zero however how many you
are using C sharp seven yeah yeah
alright so yeah I can because I'm
checking here both the shape and the
value of this expression I can just use
pattern matching so just get rid of all
that there we go nice and readable
so that's pattern matching by the way
and so now that I know it's of size zero
I just create my diagnostic so created
diagnostic so I created it I give it
that descriptor so it wants like Oh what
are all the like data or in details
about this that we need to present so
that's that rule that we put up above up
here this rule where we said about our
default severity was what the ID was the
title from that resources file so we put
that in there and then it needs a
location so location is from the syntax
tree which we don't have right now we
have our operation so from our operation
we need to grab our syntax and then from
there get location is something that we
can call and so what's happening here is
that we need that location because we
need to know where exactly in the
document we need to draw this squiggle
and so that's why we have that so we're
saying hey squiggly under the survey
creation expression that we have so
that's that's doing and then you have to
remember to report the diagnostic which
is the number one thing I forget to do
every single time because if you don't
report it anywhere then it just is sent
into the abyss and doesn't do anything
all right so we've written it if my live
unit testing was working you would see
all my tests are passing maybe hopefully
we'll find out in a second
so you can either write unit tests I can
show you what okay except I have my
fixer in here oh maybe not no you
shouldn't have to save but here we go
let's just go to I'll show you what a
unit test looks like because they're
kind of crazy we're going to probably
fix it soon so if I come in here you can
see that you're like oh you give it
string of your program so like here I
have a zero length array and a string
and then you're saying Oh like what is
the diagnostic result you expected so
have to give it like all that
information from that resources file you
have to say where the squiggles gonna
appear and then you verify that it
happened oh you're right that's what it
was so you know hmm
we're just gonna we're just gonna run it
and see what happens so if you did f5
don't tell anyone I hate testing mmm so
if you click f5 what we're going to do
is rip a new instance of Visual Studio
we're gonna package this analyzer as an
extension with the file extension v6
install it into this Visual Studio and
then you should just be able to open up
any project write a zero length array
and then have it work so here I'm
opening a project already have some
written and in here once it opens you'll
see but because it's taking a while I'm
gonna subject you to my cow jokes mmm
what do you call a cow with no legs not
steak anyone else got anything ground
beef
so if I come to tools extensions and
updates' you'll see that my analyzer
o'rama
is installed as an extension here and so
it's running and then sure enough my
zero length arrays are squiggled and if
you can see there I hover over and it
has my message for me it did not
squiggle the one that's nonzero length
so that's how you can test that works
you're set at five we spin up a new
instance of Visual Studio install it as
an extension and you can test and see if
it works so while you have to wait for
Visual Studio load on that pretty easy
way of testing that it works besides
writing unit tests mm-hmm anyways onto
the fix
so let's write a fix so we have the code
fix provider file I come in here again
you got some boilerplate going on like
what is the title of it so what's gonna
show up in the light bulb menu then you
have like what Diagnostics is it fixing
so you can fix more than one diagnostic
with the fix we're just doing a one to
one though
and then again you're just gonna
register something that happens when
they trigger the light bulb on that
diagnostic so I'm gonna uncomment this
and I need to put my callback in here
and we're good to go so it's like you
use a raid empty what a creative name
we're gonna give it my document we're
gonna give it the diagnostic and a
cancellation token so again from here
has control dot to generate this method
ie
I should have changed my code style
rules but near the black body instead
we're gonna make this a sync all right
so what happens in a fix
again the thing that we're gonna do is
we're gonna grab the current documents
I'm gonna write this out for you grab
the current docs syntax tree then we're
going to find the node that has that
original expression in it that
arrey creation once we do that we're
going to build our fix so that means
like build a subtree so build the
subtree of our fix nice tree a tree and
once we do that we're going to swap the
original expression
for our new one and then return a
document with the new syntax tree so
does that like flow make sense so again
we're gonna find our syntax tree find
that node that we want to replace then
build up a new subtree with the syntax
that we want swap them out and then
return a document with that new tree
with the swap in it and that's boom are
fixed that's all it is all right so
let's do it so here we can come in here
did you grab our root so it's an extra
you get by the root so we have a
document and thank goodness for Intel a
code because it has the thing that I
want the top so get our syntax root I
have to make it async one day I'll write
a code fix maybe or get someone else to
that adds the away because I always
forget it
mmm-hmm all right then we want to hope I
had a comment for it we're gonna find
that node of that expression so like
where is this array creation expression
like where is it so to get it we'll call
it the original expression so we're
gonna get our root and there's something
called fine node so we're gonna find it
and you give it a span if you see here
so again a span is that location in the
document like where is it and so luckily
that's the thing that we squiggled so we
should be able to get it here so we're
gonna from our diagnostic we reported
there is something called a location and
that has the source span so that's we're
getting there so it's going to find what
node is associated with that location in
my document so now I have my original
expression we're also going to grab our
semantic model because
are going to need it later so we're
going to it's part of the document get
semantic model again I forgot to put a
weight in here and then in order to now
build this subtree the last thing that
we need is our syntax generator so
that's that syntax generator a Pio is
talking you about we now use that and
it's gonna show you like super nicely
easily say make me this make me that and
it does it it's pretty great it's like
Beauty and the Beast
so I have a syntax generator get our
generator from our document cool
so I'm now gonna do this with edit and
continue fingers crossed so that we can
see the syntax as we're building it up
so this is like my favorite way of doing
it but yeah so we'll see it real quick
but before I do that lets us stub out
what our subtree is gonna be so how do
we know what this is gonna look like so
we want it to be like no something like
empty and whatever this is what we want
to change it to we can use the syntax
visualizer inside Visual Studio and so
you just like you know come to your
quick launch and type syntax visualizer
I also could have used this to show you
earlier that the different ways of
mooing up a zero length array have
different syntax trees but I will just
do it here instead so I can select this
expression and then you'll notice that
it highlighted itself in this huge tree
associate with my document and so I can
come in here and be like oh it's an
invocation expression that has a some
simple member access expression in it
which has you know this type in it and a
generic etc and so as you click on these
you can see them also highlighted in the
document so you can see it's
highlighting the empty int here and then
when I come here it's highlighting the
array so I can see what all the
different parts of this and
tax our and so this is an easy way of
identifying what the heck this tree
looks like we don't have it for the eye
operation tree yet but we're gonna build
it so rather than seeing just a syntax
tree you'll also be able to see the eye
operation tree in here as well but right
now you can't so sorry but you don't
need it y'all are smart you know all
right so we have an invocation
expression that simple member access
expression then we have you know that
array type that we have to get and then
we have a generic that we have to build
so I'm just gonna stub these out in
comments so that we can remember what
we're building as we do it so at its
root it's an invocation expression which
is gonna be this part I'm now gonna use
ctrl D which duplicates a line new
feature anyways so then we have our memo
yeah I remember access expression which
is this control D come back we need our
generic which is just this control D now
we need our type expression which was
just array and that is the syntax that
we're going to build up right so that's
what we're gonna build up in this
subtree let's just kill this alright
cool so now we're going to just start
debugging so we ran again f5 then we're
going to hit our light bulb and then
we're news edit and continue and the
immediate window to see ourselves
building up the syntax and see what's
happening all right cow joke number two
what do you call a cow with two legs
anyone anyone crickets
lean beef you're welcome you're welcome
I'll be here all week look we might have
time for one more you men uh all right
what do you call a cow that jumps over a
barbed wire fence shredded beef is a
good guess but not quite it
anyone else an utter disaster all right
okay no more jokes
hmm so from this you know I hover over
CEO and ii soslow use a raid on empty of
a press control dot i'm now hit my
breakpoint we are going to have to deal
because on same screen that the UI
elements drawn over okay so hopefully
it'll be okay uh so oh it's really mmm
let's move my immediate window maybe
over here instead that might have made
it worse okay well we'll just come back
to it when we need it all right
so here we are let's build our type
expression first so to do this from our
semantic model we're going to grab so we
can like see here a semantic model we
have a compilation we want to get a type
named by met it so we're gonna get our
type by metadata name so we're just
gonna find system array in that
compilation and use that so that's gonna
be our array type that we've just
grabbed there and then now we need to
wrap it up inside of an expression so to
do that we're gonna do the like type
expression and then we can use that
generator API and this is all you do you
get a like dot and you type in the name
that you wanted find type expression and
now we're just gonna wrap this around
the array type all right so to show that
works we're just gonna step come to our
immediate window
goto type expression and just to string
that all day yeah boom our syntax so to
string if your to string on any of our
like nodes or whatever we just like
string output whatever it is this is how
you can easily verify your syntax that
you're building up all right so now
we've done that come back up here now
let's build our generic expression so
the tricky part of this is that we need
to know what the generic type is so what
is the type of this array if we go to
our documentation will notice that in
our IRA creation operation we only have
dimension sizes and what the initializer
is so that doesn't contain anything
related to the type of the array or the
element type in the array so we're gonna
just pray that I operation has something
so if we go to eye operation interface
that implements Scroll in here oh
there's something called type that
sounds promising if we look at it what
it is so it's an eye type symbol if I
come in here not seeing much but like
what implements this so I can double
click to see references and then sure
enough over here there's something
called an eye array type symbol so if I
click on this oh I from zoomed in all
right there we go and look in here oh
look at that beautiful there's something
called element type that gets the type
of the elements store in the array so
that's what we need perfect
so come back over here not to my
debugging session come back over here so
we need to get what this type is so
first we need to get our operation in
order to get any of this because it was
all through the eye operation API so in
order to get that again if you remember
from that diagram from before from the
semantic model you can grab your
operation so in here I can get my
operation so I want it for my original
expression
those came the operation for that from
there I need to get our symbol our type
symbol type symbol which all this is I
put all this code on my github so I'll
share the length of that later but you
all can access this anytime you want so
from that we're going to one my day Oh
getting that so from my operation it has
a type so that was that type but then we
want to cast it as that I array type
symbol and then from this I can get that
element type so as my element type so
from my type symbol now I can get that
element type cool so now I know what
this value is
now I need to do the other part so let's
just construct this generic expression
so again I go to my generator ice type
dot it's probably called generic
something and sure enough generic name
is there so I give it my identifier
which is empty and then whatever my
element type is alright so let's like
prove this did what we thought it was
gonna do so again you can step I got a
love edit and continue come back over in
my immediate window type of my generic
expression to string that and I can see
I have empty of type string or whatever
it's going to be cool now have that
cool now for the easy part because we're
just wrapping all we did all the hard
part which you know was finding like
array type and the generic and now we're
just like you know adding parentheses
essentially and stitching them together
so from here oh no no no no I forgot to
move this move this up hopefully this
works all right so from here right my
remember access expression so again go
to my generator
sure enough member access expression
like we tried to make this as easy as
possible so I'm just going to feed it my
type expression so that was where I'm
getting that array and then we're going
to dot it with now that generic
expression that we wrote so again step
over it come in here say member acts
this expression to string it now you can
see it's system dot array die empty of
the type that we wanted so we've built
up that syntax there oops alright and
now the last and final piece of the
subtree let's go back the invocation
expression so it has to be an invocation
expression at the roots so invocation
expression take our generator invocation
expression and then just wrap our member
access expression in that boom and so
now i should be able to step come over
here and you get the point right you
know i'm coming over here and verifying
but it's really helpful especially if
it's your first time riding an analyzer
to come through and just to string
everything and make sure that's building
up what you thought it was so now i can
see this is exactly what i wanted it's
that array dot empty of whatever my type
is as an invocation expression cool so
now that we did all of that we have to
do these final steps so remember a swap
that original expression with the new
one so now I have this invocation
expression I want to swap that where my
original expression was in the tree so
to do that we're gonna create a new tree
we're gonna come to the old one and
there's something called replace node so
we make this easy for you and you give
it the old node which is our original
expression give it our new one which is
our invocation expression and then I
just need to make a new document with
that new syntax tree in it so in a
create a new document and then going to
say document dot with syntax you with
syntax for you I guess in Teleco t' is
totally trained on all this so nice and
easy give it my new route and then now I
need to return my new document so now o
up here I misspelled it Oh also if I
decide to want to keep that we offer to
fix your spelling mistakes for you in
here and so offers switches so we'll
just keep it misspelled why not okay so
I undo my breakpoint undo my very point
so now actually go to click continue to
go back through my thing that I've been
debugging this whole time
so I've come over here and do control
dot it now will offer to make this in a
raid empty so pretty nifty eh yeah thank
you
so mmm yeah and so you can see that I
didn't have to generate that diff view I
didn't have to do anything on the light
bulb I didn't have to say draw squiggle
I just said where to draw the squiggle
and so like most the heavy lifting is
already done for you with our templates
that we have here yes
of course you're gonna call me out on
that okay yeah so hmm
this only works if you have the
framework that has system dot array in
it so I should have done if I wanted to
make this more robust was when I
initially did my diagnostic I wouldn't
want to report this okay so okay a raid
on empty is only available I think in
four six of the framework I believe I
think so was when we added it so I
wouldn't ever want to squiggle it and
change it for someone that was not on
for six or greater so what I would need
to do is here if I want to make this
truly robust when I report the
diagnostic I would want to I'm debugging
let's stop debugging what I would want
to do is wrap this whole thing and wrap
this whole thing in a compilation start
action and if I do that then in here I'm
great at variable naming by the way then
in here I would want to see like so I
want to see that array type exists so
then I would come in grab my compilation
and just like we did to get that type
come on compilation then I would get
type by metadata name and see if system
dot array existed and so here I would
see if this exists and then like you
know if you know I forget what is this
so if it's not null or whatever it I'm
supposed to do for my check there then I
would put this in so then this now does
the check to see do you have a sister
not array available in your compilation
and it will only offer to give the
diagnostic and the fix if it exists oh
okay what was your question then I see
ok well let's find out shall we
so the question is if you they don't
have the using for this fix what happens
I believe we add it for you but there's
only one way to truly know and that
would be to test it oh I don't have any
more but I have fungus jokes you all
know the fungus is oh someone have a
joke for me ok so the joke is how do you
count cows is this appropriate by the
way whoever set it with the calculator
it's pretty good I would I'm gonna take
that mm-hmm
how does a cow count how many legs it
has cuz apparently they're flying off
the shelves
alright so in it oh maybe I'm not
targeting even the right thing here
ok let's see control dot let's see what
happens
oh it doesn't do anything because it's
always qualified it yeah oh nice look
what we do we're so like even you're
less work for you guys you have to check
that is there so yep there you go and so
now I correctly checked that as I should
have done the beginning but I don't to
make a more complicated that this exists
in there compilation and then offers it
and then yeah if you don't have the
using will qualify it for you and put it
in there cool all right what time am i
over 40 okay I'm eight minutes so I just
brag to all that I operation was so a
abstract or high-level that it works
over multiple languages so let's test it
you say what languages it applies to up
here so we're going to do language names
Visual Basic
and then we'll do it for the fix as well
I believe I stayed here language names
visual basic alright so now let's go and
test it again and open up a VB project
where we do same thing and see if it
works
alright why did the mushroom go to the
party anyway anyway we're on to funguses
now because he was a fungi I know guys
thanks for laughs alright mmm the other
one that you have to tell is you can't
tell like that joke that time opposite
direction one why did the fungus leave
the party because there wasn't mushroom
terrible but hey maybe you'll make
friend tonight who knows tell some jokes
alright and so here we are loaded thank
goodness cuz I'm out of jokes open a VB
file hopefully hopefully hopefully once
my analysis runs yep now you can see
that same thing here it's got our same
message and I should be able to do
control dot and yep it offers to use it
and uses the VB syntax for me so because
use a syntax generator API it's language
agnostic Allah creating my syntax so it
used the VB syntax in here for me and
where's the VB as well so cool that's
how we wrote it in again like if we look
at how much code that was besides my
like comment craziness that I put in
here the fix was probably like 20 lines
maybe 15 lines of code here so not a lot
and then remember our analyzer was
barely any at all just this so once you
like wrap your head around like what
that you do which once you write the
first analyzer and get
work writing anything thereafter is
usually much easier so yeah there you go
so back to slides yeah alright so here
you go here's an analyzer I wrote for
you guys
analyzers are not scary hmm
so yeah yeah that's that's the takeaway
if you want to see what some
community-based analyzers exist there
today so some people will have like gone
ham so we have like we're writing a
bunch of the FX cop analyzers or FX cop
rules as a Rawls and analyzers so you
get live feedback on whether or not
you're using the best practices from FX
cop or like the security things so we've
written a lot of those as analyzers a
lot of those news I operation so if you
want to see that in works you can look
at our repo for that
Rozlyn eater it's something like a guy
wrote 180 refactorings and code fixes or
something like that so if you need
examples or he might have written one
that you want like check it out someone
on my team wrote a bunch of style cop
analyzers as part of his open-source
project that he has for this so I wrote
all the style cop rules as Roz and
analyzers so you can use that Soner cube
I wrote one a bunch for a STONER lint I
think they also have hundreds and
there's code cracker which is another
kind of grassroots one that popped up
that does a lot of VB ones as well I
believe so if you want to like see
examples in the wild or use them
yourself so you can contribute to these
projects write your own a lot of people
have written their own for their teams
at their company or whatever yeah and
then here is a ton of references for you
so like if you want to learn more about
the api's we have a nice overview that I
didn't write which is why it's really
good then if you want that source code
index so what I've been calling the
documentation that's or start on the i/o
we have various guides to help you get
started if you really want to find
analyzers exist today we don't have a
registry or anything so you just sort of
have to like google Roslyn analyzers or
go to nougat org and type
Eliezer or go to the extension gallery
and click analyser and do that someone
made this website called awesome Roslyn
which sounds pretty cool right
skip verification let's just oh you
can't see it escape escape
oh no how do I get out of presentation
mode okay here we go
and so it's like a list of books on
Roslyn tutorials on Roslyn and different
open-source projects that use Roslyn so
that's something that you want you can
do that and oh man this is yeah so you
did my job for me and put all this in
here for you so that's awesome Roslyn is
the github project for that that you can
use etc and yeah I think that's it how
much time I have a three minutes so does
anyone have any questions
oh yeah so the questions was the
performance of these we're actually
building a tool right now to be able to
measure the performance of these we
don't actually have a way of doing it
right now there's certain actions that
you shouldn't well no they shouldn't
register too but that request so if you
write anything that requires the entire
couple so accomplish an end to action
that requires the whole compilation to
be done in order to access that so that
one will have like you know will take
longer than the other ones but if you
write these unless you like are writing
infinite loops and then or mining
Bitcoin in them they should be
performing
so the question is can I just like have
the so in my example could I've just
done a system daughter ADA empty of the
type and just have it generate the
syntax tree for me someone wrote a tool
that does that
I believe sort of but yeah okay so it
has to for the array I needed to make
sure that it was current I can't just
have like a string identifier array I
need to be the array linked to system
dot array and I need to know like my
generic type and so how would you get
that from a string input right
I believe those someone I can't remember
the name of the tool but it's like just
do like Roslyn string it to what is it
called
oh yeah Roslyn quota that's what it is
Roslyn quota and if you go there you
just type in like what syntax you wanted
and it shows you what you have to build
out with the generator of the syntax
factory to get it yeah so people have
written like all sorts of cool tools for
writing these in Roslyn as well so go
wild any other questions
cool well as I said if you're not here
for my comedy I'll be here all week
so just find me at any time and happy to
talk about whatever so also if you want
to write these the Rosslyn team our team
has a git er channel Gator dot I am
slash Rosslyn or something like that so
if you're having trouble with any
analyzer that you're writing just hop on
to get her and like our entire team is
there so you can just ask us any
question you have and we're happy to
help so yeah thanks guys for coming out
enjoy the rest of NBC Thanks